il ne voulait pas mourir mais il n'en
pouvait plus de souffrir je veux vous
parler ici de Nicolas que nous
connaissions bien à Poissy lui et sa
famille ce poison du harcèlement qui a
consumé ce jeune adolescent jusqu'à son
impensable geste de désespoir la
pendaison
ce harcèlement qui saute aux yeux mais
qu'on ne veut pas voir
déclinaison en trois points une
altercation avec les harceleur le 30
septembre dernier dans la cour à l'heure
du déjeuner tu es moche tu es nul je
vais baiser ta mère sous les yeux d'un
enseignant qui dira ne rien pouvoir
faire car les faits se sont déroulés à
la pause méridienne
une rencontre ensuite des parents avec
le proviseur pour crier à l'aide réponse
de l'intéressé je vous ai fait part de
mon interrogation d'être sollicité en
mars pour une situation dont vous avez
connaissance supposément depuis
septembre il n'y a pas plus aveugle que
celui qui ne veut pas voir
le cauchemar enfin celui du rectorat qui
dans une missive sans âme nous plonge
dans un dégoût sans nom dans l'intérêt
de votre enfant et par souci
d'exemplarité à son égard je vous
enjoins d'adopter une attitude
constructive menace à la clé les
victimes deviennent coupables nous avons
tous notre part de responsabilité dans
cette chaîne d'éducation où chaque
maillon façonne le bien-être et le bien
vivre de nos futurs générations mais
combien de temps encore Monsieur le
Directeur l'éducation nationale
va-t-elle se draper dans des postures de
cécité et de surdité
aujourd'hui il y a quasiment pas une
situation de harcèlement qui n'est pas
son prolongement cyber
et avec du coup
des jeunes qui n'ont plus aucun espace
ni aucun temps pour échapper alors cela
et ça c'est effrayant la règle qui a été
inscrite dans les textes et c'est
nouveau aussi depuis le mois de août
c'est que désormais tout acte de
harcèlement doit faire l'objet d'une
sanction disciplinaire
jusqu'à présent c'est des vrais pour les
actes commis à l'encontre des personnels
c'était il y avait une ouverture sur son
disciple de procédure obligatoire
uniquement dans ce type d'hypothèse
désormais on a ouvert en disant à partir
de mon harcèlement une procédure
disciplinaire doit nécessairement être
ouverte